right now I take the phone call of New
York Daily News Frank Isola he's is the
most New York I can get right now here
on the Rich Eisen show how are you Frank
okay we're rich there's one thing most
of us aren't going to give up yeah
that's our cell phone that's not an easy
thing to give up what if a federal judge
says you got it
right ladies gotta come find you maybe
I'll leave the country with myself okay
oh my gosh
that's like it's like we treat it like
it so most prized possession [ __ ] our
entire life is in that phone plus a lot
of things we don't want people to know
about but probably in that phone as well
so now you know it's week nine in the
NFL season and again I know beer all
over the mixes as always but I just saw
a lot of jet fans that were jubilant
last night and MetLife they're four and
five right now Frank but personally I'm
conflicted because I see they're four
and five with a 38 year old quarterback
they still don't know if Bryce petty or
Christian Hackenberg can play all 16
games or the fact that they're just
gonna ride Josh McCown as long as they
have gives you all what they think about
who those two quarterbacks are and
whether they're viable franchise
quarterbacks and then what's the game
plan even if they do make the playoffs
I'm wondering how well how folks here in
New York I've handled that well for one
you know they should have won the game
against the winner or they should have
been in a better position to win they
got jobs on that one bad calm and
obviously they were competitive against
Atlanta so that's back you know playing
the Superbowl the two teams in the
Superbowl at home they probably should
have won both games but I don't buy all
that tanking nonsense you know the NFL
it's such a crapshoot
taking a quarterback so high I mean
Brady will be a six round pick and he's
gonna go down maybe it's the best
quarter you know the greatest
quarterback of all time three it's about
building a winning culture which is
something they need in New York so
follow them yeah tell me you got to go
out try to win every week and wherever
you you draft hopefully your scouting
department is smart enough where there
is a quarterback available kind of like
what used to did with the Shaun Watson
and I guess they trade it up to get him
but I did thought it was a pretty smart
move so you know I think you're going to
every NFL season what's the lifespan of
NFL players their career three years
maybe to me every year it's about you
know trying to win try to go to the
playoffs because you now only come on
the draft is a it's an
exact science it's really the most part
of crapshoot so I think what the Jets
are doing is better than saying Alice
just give up on the season I don't go
along with that and what's the sense of
been in this town about McAdoo and his
viability to stay put as the Giants head
coach right it doesn't look good and
usually when the players start acting
out the way that they did and I thought
a lot of those guys not getting you know
returning home in time for practice on
Monday now they have they lost week and
I get it the weather was bad on Sunday
but when you're a committed team you
make sure that you get back and I
thought that was a bad look and it just
shows it all it does is lead to the idea
that the head coach is not in charge and
when you add the losses to it it's just
a bad look all the way around I would
have to think unless something dramatic
happens I would have to think that
they're going to seriously consider
making a coaching change at the end of
well who would that be do you think that
there's a shortlist and in John Merrow
Steve Tisch or or is Jerry risa I don't
even know if he'd be the one that would
be that I saw such a thing I think
that's the first thing that would
probably happen is Jerry Reese can be
the guy that makes the choice I would
mind going with you're a guy that would
be the first phone call I would make you
guys absolutely I mean he's probably not
going to take it but I would call him
why not I don't know if honestly I don't
that's such a you know a topic that
everybody always has the front of their
mind
I mean Harbaugh is making a nice chunk
of change sitting there with his dad
living next door and you know his kids
growing up just like he did watching dad
coach the Michigan Wolverines I I don't
know how that why he would leave
Michigan quite frankly I understand that
but I would that would be the first
phone call we make dislike the same
thing with the Knicks every time they've
had like they're changing management my
first phone call would have been to that
rally in Miami I don't think that Miami
would let him go I don't think that
Tyrod would take but why would you call
him why don't you go after one of the
best guys the worst he can do is say no
and I think it's his I agree with you I
don't think Jim Harbaugh would leave
Michigan especially this early into his
run I think he's committed there and I
mean come on the guy's smart enough for
eventually he's going to win the
national champions
there were come close to anyone so I
don't think he would leave but I would
certainly ask him because we know that
he could be successful at this level
with let's face it you know there's so
much talk about Colin Kaepernick all the
time with it you know slightly above
average quarterback he went you know he
went to a bunch of NFC championship
games came very close to winning a Super
Bowl so we know that he can succeed in
the NFL Frank I sold with the Daily News
here in the Rich Eisen show my first
call and again this is not a Michigan
thing here okay where I'm like stay keep
your hands off of my coach because if
Harbaugh wants to leave at some point
and he's got a shot then you know then
then go with God you know if you don't
want to stay then then go but I don't
think he's got the I don't think he's
that guy and I don't want to see him go
but I'm saying again I've said this
before and I'll say it again if I had
need a coach in the NFL first call I
make is to David Sean Stanford first guy
yeah because he and they've had a track
record there to happen but I'm Eeva draw
has has has coached in the NFL as a as
an assistant and he's just the face of a
franchise that I'd want to put out there
he is that guy yeah he's the guy that
you don't know if you're winning or
losing when you just look at him on the
sideline he knows offense would you have
to have in this league right now I'd
rather have an offensive minded head
coach than a defensive minded head coach
any day of the week in the throwing
first league and certainly if you've got
Odell Beckham and you've got all those
guys out there that you can put out
there on offense he'd be the first guys
on the Giants that I would call is David
Wright I think that's a good name let me
ask you this do you think it's easier
for a college coach to make the
adjustment from being a college coach to
an NFL coach than it is from a college
basketball coach to go to the NBA I just
think that the NBA players perceive
college coaches a little bit differently
than NFL players receive college coaches
it seems like the college coaches in
football have maybe a little more cachet
than maybe some of the college
basketball guys well David Shaw could
come in and say hey I've been around Ray
Lewis what about you you know I mean
like so he's got that that in his is
again I don't want to poach Stanford's
coach to all the Stanford listeners out
there but again if I would I would buddy
and in the same way though that
Harbaugh's kids are in Ann Arbor dad
lives next door
David Shaw's family is ensconced in Palo
Alto it would take it would take quite a
bunch of good stuff to try and get him
out of there but you know oh and I would
think for a lot of these guys I could
jog here talking about like Shaw it
stands for Gemara of Michigan but one
thing about the Giants job if you're a
coach you look at ownership number one
and you know that the ownership in New
York is very stable they have a winning
tradition they're you know they have
very good players are always going to be
committed to winning all the time they
have a great fan base and obviously it's
in New York and all that other stuff so
that to me in regards to the fact that
the Giants are terrible this year and
the record is terrible I should say I
still think most people would be with us
a plum job there's a couple minutes I
have left with Frank I soloed the daily
news around the horn PTI etc here on the
Rich Eisen show I had Maverick Carter in
studio on Wednesday the business
associate of of LeBron James and and
good good buddy from back in the day and
I refuse to use the word that Phil
Jackson used obviously frankly I asked
him I asked him if where LeBron plays
fits into any of his business strategy
certainly if he's transitioning into the
entertainment world coming out of his
playing days and he said not the one
only thing that matters is where he's
gonna go is to win that's it that he
could have meetings anywhere he could
shoot movies and in any offseason
regardless of where he is
what are your thoughts on that
supposition from Maverick Carter on the
show it's up to you first I heard the
interview I thought it was a really good
interview maverick or is a very smart
guy but I would say this too the one
business opportunity that could be there
with the Lakers could be a part of
ownership then that to me that kind of
changes thing I agree if I'm LeBron at
this stage of my career and I understand
right now the Cavaliers have been
terrible if they lose tonight believe it
or not that's going to be five straight
losses for them it won't we need to gain
their in Washington and Washington's
coming off a loss as well but to me
staying in Cleveland for one more year
Lisa keeps you out of the Western
Conference where the Golden State
Warriors are so even when it's a new in
the season start it's it's almost like
the Cavaliers are four wins away from
winning an NBA champion as opposed to
going out west and I try to navigate
your way through speech only it's a
pretty inexperienced Laker team even if
we brought a player like Paul George
along with them yes to me is still not
as good as the Golden State Warriors by
staying east especially in Cleveland I
think he's going to be 33 on December 30
to stay one more year that means you'd
be 34 next year to me that would be the
smart way for him to go give yourself to
more legitimate seasons to make a real
run at it and remember you know the one
thing about Cleveland they I don't
believe that they would trade that net
stick but they do have some interesting
players on their team Kevin Love
Tristan Thompson what if you combine one
of those players with the net stick
could you get a player like the Marcus
Cousins I'm sure you would shoot for the
moon and try to get somebody like
Anthony Davis so I still think that
Cleveland if things are really going
poorly for them where they're you know
just hanging over 500 a little bit maybe
by February they would decide to do
something drastic I agree with what
maverick heart is saying LeBron is one
of the biggest athletes most popular
athletes in the world regardless of
where he's gonna play but I do think
business factors into it from this
standpoint that if he ends up in LA with
the Lakers could eventually ki be part
of ownership there well first of all
just in a couple minutes have with you
left here is that legal can you do that
can you offer a player ownership still
wink wink I got it okay yeah and
certainly then when you're done play
but that said though why why not the
Clippers because the Clippers have Jerry
West sitting there the Godfather who
whispered and Kevin Durant's ear and
then I'm sure LeBron listens to and this
again this is my supposition just
sitting on my couch and also having
interviewed maverick Carter and as you
pointed out this guy's a brilliant
strategist along with LeBron they're
really smart why would they want to
attach LeBrons brand at the end of his
playing career with that of Lavar balls
why would they want to do that here yeah
that's and if you look at the Clippers
roster - with Blake Griffin with DeAndre
Jordan and if LeBron to bring something
I don't really you know the salary cap
situation it might have to jump through
hoops to make some moves but that from a
basketball standpoint and we know that
Doc Rivers and LeBron have a very good
relationship in fact I think LeBron went
and wasn't the story
years ago that they were trying to lobby
pop rivets to somehow become their coach
hitting Miami so I I would definitely
think that would be in play plus you
know if Ron if LeBron wins with the
Lakers his number just goes up there
with a dozen others if he wins with the
Clippers there's one number in the
rafters I mean seriously you go to
Staples for a Lakers game you see the
banners all over the place you go to a
Clippers staples for a Clippers games
they just have photographs on the wall
of the country Clippers FairPoint and
what if they brought it what if LeBron
was able to bring it's not closer to
maybe Carmelo you add into a team we
already have DeAndre Jordan and you have
Blake Griffin obviously and have some
good role players including Lou Williams
that you know what it might not be a bad
team to try to go make a run at it all
right Frank we were going to give you a
James Dolan quiz but we'll just do that
the next time okay next time we're
coming back to New York we're doing two
shows wrapped around the Titans and
Steelers in Pittsburgh so we'll see in a
couple weeks maybe okay that's Frank I
so love the New York Daily News for more
Rich Eisen show tuned to audience
channel 239 or DirecTV or download the
Rich Eisen show app